90 c'est évidemment pas que de la télé
c'est aussi des objets qui ont marqué
une époque on était je pense poussière
d'avoir à cette époque la dame
alors cette semaine belle victoire dans
le focus group n'a fait demander si ces
objets parler aux enfants d'aujourd'hui
sa réponse tout de suite
en bougeant les enfants bonjour genre
salut merci d'être venu aujourd'hui
alors je vais vous montrer des objets
vous allez me dire si vous les
connaissez et si vous ne connaissez pas
d'après vous à quoi ça servait d'accord
allez on commence avec celui là d'après
vous qu'est ce que c'est j'ai pas touché
ouais aller l'a compris la cour mais
l'ordinateur un ordinateur pour les
aînés et demi parce que dans les années
90 d'après temps on était surtout en
guerre oui contre qui un éclair est
clair d'accord et ça c'était pour battre
les nazis ah oui on va on commence par
là mais il ya des gens qui sont
rencontrés grâce au minitel et jean
michel maire était beaucoup sur 36 15 où
là on passe au suivant
alors attention
je sais c'est nul l'imprimante 3d
c'était la télé qui était à l'époque
c'est le premier mac c'est le premier
mac donc ça vous passionne le bac a
alors qu'ils annoncent étaient les
premiers portables
ma famille est là encore allons macron
pourquoi sa ligne directe des manières
oui l'année passée ma grand mère dans
son maquis rejoint sa grand-mère là bas
que je jouais un lecteur dvd un lecteur
de cassettes crois que mes de la musique
est que et que la cbc la saison c'était
la première console de jeux vidéo mais
des jeux vidéo jeux avec des manettes
si tu veux que je reconduis à face ou
six autres objets enfin c'est pas
vraiment un objet
c'est un bon temps c'est johnny hallyday
parce que dans les années 90 celui qui
était sur les billets s'étaient abonnés
de la france dans les années 90 c'était
quoi vinard dinars bon le dollar est
pour toi tu penses chances des péjoces
qu est attelé au petit déjeuner
exactement ici
et attention à ce qu'on met dans ton
petit déjeuner ça d'après vous c'est
quoi
photo j je sais une lampe de poche à mon
avis lampe de poche quand les
codes-barres ouais c'est quoi alors ça
sert de ses 1 2
ses soeurs tassé 7% suspense toi ça
s'appelle un tatoo à quoi ça pouvait
servir ça à fin mai les tatouages
donc on faisait ça et ça me fait un
tatouage oui on trouve de température
un thermomètre mais on est bien d'accord
c'est aux températures extérieures c'est
pas pour prendre sa température
sinon sympa par autret apporte beaucoup
faire attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]